in what sounds like a completely made-up
story that is sadly very very real
Republican South Carolina representative
Ralph Norman pulled out a loaded gun
during a meeting about preventing gun
violence over the weekend and he
specifically pulled it out I mean it's
just the logic of it is so bizarre to
show the people that were in the room
just how much safer everybody is because
of the presence of that gun and also
that the gun just sitting inert on a
tabletop is not going to fire itself and
he also reportedly left it out the
entire rest of the meeting which in some
states would actually be the crime of
brandishing a firearm I think where you
live in California they have a pretty
strong brandishing a firearm law South
Carolina this is perfectly legal almost
welcomed in some ways the image I have
in my mind is straight up mafia like
like you someone comes in and says they
need to talk to you and they take the
gun out and they put it on the table
they don't necessarily mention like I
could maybe use the gun on you but it's
there in the corner of your eye the
whole time they were telling you what it
is that they want you to do and Norman
isn't denying this he said that he did
it he said to the Post and Courier he
did it to illustrate that guns don't
shoot people people shoot people which
of course most reasonable people get
that in principle guns don't
spontaneously discharge other than those
Remington rifles the story which we
covered a couple months ago which is a
horrible story but generally speaking
other than the guns that do fire
themselves most guns don't fire
themselves but the point of that phrase
is really lost on me because the real
problem is that ready access to very
powerful guns drastically increases the
killing power of the people with the
guns and I don't know if that's a
talking point you deal with often maybe
not if and if not you're lucky because
of where you live but guns don't kill
people people kill people to me seem
it's so ridiculous that it sometimes
becomes hard to even argue against in a
way well I mean where I live I'm I'm
living just outside of Oakland yeah and
people are using guns to kill people all
the time sure and so when I go on
because I have radar season tickets and
we have tons of metal detectors but as
we're going into the stadium I'm
constantly thinking of the fact that if
someone had a high-powered rifle
we're going through the security line
yeah they can mow down a bunch of us in
fact I go in first quarter most of the
time just they don't want to be in that
situation because I'm aware that people
have guns around me I never feel safer
because of that fact I feel safer inside
the stadium after I know that everyone's
gone through metal detector sure so just
the idea that this guy's pulling it out
and he's like this is for your safety I
instantly would have felt less safe just
knowing it was there but now the the
counter-argument though would be
wouldn't you feel safer in the sort of
staging area to go in to the Raiders
stadium if it wasn't presumably a
gun-free zone and you knew everybody was
armed because then no shooter would be
stupid enough to show up there and shoot
anybody right no there are people
packing heat in that parking lot all the
time we all know it so that's already
situation it's not a gun-free zone out
in the parking lot where we tailgate all
the time like no there's guns everywhere
yeah we're aware of it and the only
thing that concerns me is if someone
does go and hide in the plants first of
all hiding in the plants there's gonna
be some people killed before even know
where the guy is yeah
well what are we gonna do have everyone
in the line pull out their guns and now
we have crossfire like I don't want to
get hit by the crossfire that's why I
mean we've talked about this before Pat
like when you actually analyze so many
of the shootings where people say well
it took place where guns aren't allowed
the Aurora movie theater shooting for
example how would a handful of armed
people in the dark movie theater have
sort of improved the situation because
immediately the gunshots are
reverberating you don't know who the
good guy with the gun is or the bad guy
with the gun it's dark anyway police
eventually show up now you've got five
people with guns do the police know who
the right person is to target and when
you actually apply it and this is where
I think the right actually does have an
advantage structurally on a lot of these
issues the idea is sort of simple and
concise and very neat like listen you
put more guns into place it's hardening
it as a target people might be dissuaded
from from coming in and doing a shooting
because they'll know that other people
will have guns in practice when you
think about it it doesn't make any sense
yeah and also saying that it's not guns
that kill people it's people who kill
people you're very simplistic you can
put that on a bumper stickers so it's
just good political messaging going down
the list of like Oh with there's you
know this contingent or this contingent
there
could lead to someone getting shot it's
not getting shot yet those people on
ones it's not gonna work
do you ever deal with that how like for
example hey abortion is murder so
abortion should be illegal it's just
such a nice neat concise argument and
like the the left-wing position is not
the opposite of that it's nuanced then
requires like five minutes to lay out
and I think that that is really actually
puts progressive ideas at a disadvantage
merely because they need more
explanation in a sense I mean yeah it's
everything is more nuanced than so many
of these things make it and even with
the the gun thing that whole idea rests
upon the fact that people don't want to
die themselves how many of these
shooters walk out of there alive you
know that they're not going to this this
YouTube crazy yeah like she shot herself
right so that's the thing if you're
going in to basically fire like die by
cops suicide by cop I think it's what
they call it if that's your goal anyway
you're just trying to take out as many
as you can so it's the gun gives them
the ability to do that absolutely in a
way that knives and pills don't yep and
we have seen that we mean it's it's it's
been seen that to happen that way so
many times that it's kind of almost just
disgusting at this point to even have to
say here's a hundred examples that we
have of where it happened in exactly
this way